When you go to get guacamole at a restaurant,
you’re told: “Guac is extra”.
No... guac is not extra!
Guac.
Is.
essential.
What’s up!
I’m Sapna here for DNews.
You guys, I have bad news.
No, terrible news.. tragic news.
Thanks to a never-ending California drought
coupled with a Mexican labor strike, we are
facing… an avocado shortage.
Yes my friends we are running short on our
favorite fruit… no I mean our favorite berry…
no wait, it’s both.
Even though you might find avocados in a veggie
salad, an avocado is actually the matured
ovary of a flower: which is a fruit.
Like nearly all fruits, it has a tough outer
layer, and a fleshy-edible second layer encapsulating
a seed.
Furthermore, it fits all the qualities of
a botanical berry, even though the berries
we’re most familiar with have a bunch of
seeds, while the avocado only has one.
So while we are temporarily deprived of our
favorite unconventional fruit, it might be
a good idea to take a break from the guac
and see if you should even be eating it.
Are avocados good for you?
Well, for starters, they’re packed with
fat.
In fact, about three quarters of the edible
calories in an avocado are pure fat.
So, will avocados make you fat?
Actually, most of the fat in avocados is thought
to be good for you.
A little more than ten percent of that fat
is saturated fat, which do you want to avoid
in excess, but the rest is healthy fats: monounsaturated
and polyunsaturated.
There is still a lot of research ` being done
about these fats and their health contributions,
but besides containing good fat, clinical
trials have shown that diets with avocado
in them can help lower what we call “bad
cholesterol” because avocados have sterols,
or “steroid alcohols” -- that’s a subclass
of steroids.
The sterols in avocados serve the same function
as cholesterols in the human body, and when
you eat an avocado its sterols are absorbed
instead of cholesterol.
Another trial out of UCLA found that avocados
might improve vascular health and even have
anti-inflammatory effects.
Barring any new discoveries about food, which
ya know happen all the time, as far as we
know right now, avocados are pretty good for
you in moderation.
And here’s one last fact, and this one is
crazy.
When most of us think of avocados, we think
of those deep dark green ones with bumpy skin.
Those, are Hass avocados… they are by far
the most commonly eaten variety -- more than
95% of avocados eaten in the United States
are Haas.
But across the country and around the world,
people eat all sorts of avocados, gigantic
smooth ones and teeny-tiny light green ones…
there is a crazy amount of avocado variety.
But here’s the amazing fact.
The Hass avocado… originated in one, and
only one tree.
Every single Hass avocado you have ever eaten,
or anyone has ever eaten, they all share a
common ancestor: the mother tree.
All Hass avocado trees are grafted from that
original tree planted by Rudolph Haas.
Since 1926, the mother tree stood in front
of a house on West Road in La Habra Heights
in Los Angeles County and in September 2002,
the tree was cut down after battling root
rot for over a decade.
So the next time you dip your chip into a
bowl of guac, yes I know it's extra- it shouldn’t
be... think of the Hass Mother Tree and say
a little thank you for the giver of guac.
But what about foods we think of as healthy
that are actually making us fat?
We have a video about that right here.
What other foods would you like to know more
about?
Let us know down in the comments and don’t
forget to like and subscribe for more DNews
every day.